♪ ♪ ♪
- Nous voici au Laboratoirede s,
une véritable fourmilière
depuis deux ans.
- C'est nous ici qui avons
fait pousser le premier...
le premier virus au Canada.
- Faire pousser unt t t t t t te
des échantillons à partir
des tests positifs de COVID-19
et on vérifie, entre autres,
le virus est capable
de se multiplier
dans les cellules.
Les résultats suggèrenteseseses
10 jours. Ces études, menées
un peu partout dans le monde,
ont influencé la durée
d'isolement crcrcrcrcrcrcrcrcrc-
infectiologue, Hôpital gén. juif
- L'une de difficultés,
par exemple, de ces études-là,
c'est qu'ides populations ou
des participants relativement
jeunes. Donc, l'âge moyen
dans ces études-là oscillait
- Le microbiologiste-infectiolo,
s'inquiétait du fait
que les personneouououououououos
plus longtemps que 10 jours
quand elles contractent
l'influenza, étant donné
immunitaire.
Pour vérifier si c'esiiii
le cas pour la COVID,
l'Hôpital général juif
22 patients de 80 ans et plusdar
en laboratoire si le virus
est toujours présent au jo
- On étaèèèès surpris.
Quand on est rendu dans l'ordre
du 12 sur 22 encore contagieux,
bien, à ce ààààà,
on se rend compte que
clairement, il se passe
Il se passe quelque chose.
- Contmême si pratiquement tous
leurs symptômes avaient dispar
Dr HUGUES CHAREST. responsable,
Labo. de santé publique du Qc
potentiel que peut causer
une personne quququququi est mae
pendant plus que 10 jours.
Donc, on sait maintenant
de ces gens-là sontcococococore.
- Cette découverte, une première
canadienne, imimimimimimimimimi:
non seulement sur la durée
d'isolement des aînés,
mais aussi sur l'équipement
des travailleurs de la santé
qui les soignent
Le Dr Longtin et son équipe
lancent un appel iiqiqiqiqiqiqis
poursuivent cette recherche
auprès d'un échantillon
plus grand.
est-ce qu'ils demeurent
contagieux 12
15 jours, 20 jours?
Notre étude ne peut pas.........
Il va falloir faire une autreeùr
suivre les patients, de façon
longitudinale, et les enenenener
pouvoir déterminer le moment
où ils ne sont plus contagieux.
- Cette étude démontre qu'on a
la contagiosité des aînés durant
e,e,e,e,e,e,e, et elle pourrait
même fournir certaines réponses
aux enqu
l'hécatombe dans les CHSLD
durant la première vague.
Ici Véronique Prince,
Radio